c'est la survie qui n'est pas le jeu en
ce moment
on pourrait l'aider l'horaire contre
l'allusion je souhaite changements
radicaux d'abord découvert le monde
maintenant on va regarder qu'est ce que
la désobéissance
une vingtaine de militants écologistes
sacrifie un beau samedi de septembre
pour apprendre la bc de la désobéissance
civile non violente
la désobéissance m envoie le message
suivant la situation est rendue à ce
point grave que je ne peux pas rester
inactif et malgré les risques et les
dangers
je décide de commettre la désobéissance
civile et d'assumer les conséquences de
mes gestes
la formation est offert par extinction
ribéry le groupe créé en grande bretagne
il ya un an a maintenant des filiales
dans une cinquantaine de pays
ses membres font des coups d'éclat comme
bloquer dépend où l'accès à des magasins
bon marché il se rebelle contre
l'économie de surconsommation qui
tentera une t'étouffer la planète selon
l'acs motive des gouvernements c'est de
pousser l'économie plus loin qu'on est
déjà là et on est déjà trop loin je vous
rends l'impression de voter pour le
moins pire
je vais voter pour le groupe ' le parti
politique qui va voir les mesures les
plus entreprenantes et qui avec qui je
vais avoir confiance que là les actions
vont suivre les paroles c'est la
question en béton pour qui je vais voter
ce jeu n'est pas encore décidée mais la
casse environnementales et les centrales
à mon choix comme bien des écologistes
philippe dumont ne pardonne pas aux
libéraux l'achat du pipeline trans
manten dans l'ouest le groupe extinction
we begin n'appuiera aucun parti mais
compte se faire entendre durant la
campagne électorale
il faudrait des cars décarboniser
l'économie pour 2025
c'est très très court il ya aucun
plafond et électorale du français
catherine bouchard tremblay est une des
porte-parole du groupe
comme les autres rebelles elle croit que
l'urgence justifie la désobéissance
civile de désobéissance civile s'est
pointé le problème si jack sommes là on
n'a plus le temps
il faut juste changer le système
l'exercice met en scène des militants
qui bloquent l'accès à un site
d'exploitation pétrolière et des
travailleurs qui tentent de passer
ils apprennent à résister aux
provocations
j'ai rampé dans un jules cgc elle est
provocante tous ceux avec qui j'ai joué
un rôle mais rapidement par sa voix son
calme ça m'a vraiment comme désabusé
[Musique]
ces jeunes manifestent pour dénoncer les
feux de forêts en amazonie
on ne choisit dans le fond de faire du
faux sang tout à partir de matières
végétales pour sont entre les mains pour
symboliser tout le drame que vivent les
communautés l'avait coup d'éclat
désobéissance civile
ils sont prêts à faire des sacrifices
pour sauver la planète et mettre les
politiciens face à leurs responsabilités
faut juste des contrats comme l accord d
paris que jamais été respectées mais des
actions concrètes pour réduire la
pollution ça veut limiter les grandes
industries limiter la déforestation
commencent à planter
oui c'est dur oui ça va ça va nuire à
notre confort pour un moment précis
certains moments mais c'est nécessaire
c'est des sacrifices qui doivent être
fait peser la crise la wii les adultes
matière mais qu'est ce que vous faites a
manqué mais colas tous les vendredis
modification est tellement importante
pour votre futur mais quelques tours si
on n'en a même pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]